[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEVE BAZYL: Hi everyone and
welcome to this week's Google
Developers Live for
Google Drive.
Today we are joined by two
developers from Floreysoft.
This is Daniel and Oliver.
They make a bunch of
really cool web
apps for Google Drive--
including Ultradox, which we
reviewed here a few months
back, and some new apps that are
some really cool editors
for developers using Drive.
I don't go into too much
detail since Daniel and
Oliver, you can tell us a little
bit more about what
you've been working on,
about Floreysoft.
And give us a demo of some
of your new apps.
DANIEL FLOREY: Thanks, Steve.
Hi, everybody.
OLIVER ZEIGERMANN: Hi.
DANIEL FLOREY: So we are
building apps for the Google
platform since 2008.
And so we started with a very
small application that allows
you to share contacts between
different accounts.
We've been in the Enterprise
world for a
very long time now.
And so Enterprise applications
used to be like, boring apps
for boring people.
But we thought that
on the Google
platform we could do better.
And so, yes, I would like
to show you some of our
applications and of course
mainly the ones that are
integrated into Google Drive.
So maybe I can just get started
by sharing my screen
and hopefully you will
be able to see it.
So this is the application I've
been talking about, the
Shared Groups application, where
you can share contacts
between different Google or
Google Apps accounts.
So that was the one we've
been starting with.
It sounds quite simple, because
you just keep contacts
in sync between different
accounts.
But technically it's
quite challenging.
It's based on the Google
App Engine.
And once we did that, we thought
Enterprises also would
need real Enterprise contact
management application.
So this was the second one that
we created, also based on
App Engine.
And it's more or less comparable
with a Gmail
contact manager.
But it also provides a bunch of
features targeted towards
the Enterprise.
For example, you will find all
the fields in the contact
manager that are available in
the contact API but are not
available in the Google
Mail contact manager.
So you will find all these
fields in here.
And this was the first time
that we got in touch with
Google Drive.
So we added the capability to
add documents and files from
Google Drive to contacts.
So if you do that, this will
launch the [INAUDIBLE]
on Google file [INAUDIBLE].
And it will store the files
as URL in the contacts.
So that you are able to open the
files also from your Gmail
contact manger, but it looks
a little bit nicer in here.
And maybe another feature that
I would like to show is that
you can create organization
charts for your contacts.
And this is built using the
Play end framework that is
based on the Google
Web Toolkit.
And we also have some
Google Maps
integration, stuff like that.
So if you select multiple
contexts you will see them on
Google Maps.
And all of this is
quite easy when
leveraging the cloud platform.
So from a development
perspective, it never has been
easier to integrate nice
features without doing much
coding yourself.
STEVE BAZYL: And the contact
manager, for those who are
interested in it, that's
available in the Google Apps
Marketplace, correct?
DANIEL FLOREY: Yes, right.
So you can add it to your own
Google Apps domain and this
will be available domain-wide
for your Google Apps users.
And if you're using Gmail, we
also have a nice integration
to your Google mail interface.
So that you can open up this
contact manager in a gadgets
view right in your
Gmail interface.
So that you can copy and paste
some information from your
mail right to the contacts.
So you are able to edit
the contacts right
in the Gmail interface.
OK, now to the applications
that we've created from
scratch for Google Drive.
So the first one is our
Ultradox application.
This one allows you to create
and print PDFs online right
from the cloud.
And we are leveraging a lot
of Google stuff here.
For example, we are using Google
Cloud Print to be able
to create and print documents
right from the
cloud on your printer.
I'm not going to show that, but
you can check it out if
you are interested.
And this application will more
or less assemble data from
different data sources and
generate a PDF from this data.
So this example that I've just
opened, typical example where
you want to create
invoices based on
data from time sheets.
So if you're working as a
freelancer, this makes sense.
So you can track your times
in a Google spreadsheet.
I've just switched into the
expert mode, where you can
customize this document.
If you click on edit, it will
open the time sheet right from
Google drive, and you can make
changes and generate a new
invoice based on data
in your spreadsheet.
And the template that
we are using to
generate the document--
it's also just good
old Google Docs.
So you can just launch our
template editor and then you
will find just a Google document
with some magic place
holders in it.
And they will allow you to
generate nice-looking tables
or embed the pie chart from your
spreadsheet right into
the generated PDF document.
STEVE BAZYL: I remember when you
launched this app, we did
a quick review of it a few
days after it launched.
And it's a great app, and I know
you've done a lot of work
on it in the past few months to
add out some new features.
But it definitely fills
a big gap for people
who use Google Docs--
adding those mail merge
capabilities, templating and
all sorts of dynamic
documents.
It's an app I actually really
enjoy using and find valuable.
DANIEL FLOREY: So it's quite
a complex beast.
So it's not something that
the end user really
gets at first sight.
But if you dive into the
functionality you can do a lot
of stuff with it.
One feature that we were looking
to integrate was,
sometimes people want to have
some more sophisticated logic
into their documents.
For example, if they have a
Google Form where users submit
some data, then they want
to do some sophisticated
calculations and
then render the
output into their documents.
And so we were looking for a
very simple JavaScript editor
that we could embedded into
this application so that
people would be able to just
select and create JavaScript
files in the same way that they
can do it right now with
the spreadsheets, other
contacts, other documents.
And that was the reason that I
started to look at the Chrome
Web Store, if I could find a
very, very simple JavaScript
editor for Google Drive.
And I found a lot
of great ideas.
But they all looked too
complicated for our use case.
So I decided to create
something
really simple from scratch.
And so that's the latest
addition to our applications.
It's called Editey, and it comes
with a bunch of very
simple editors.
So for example, if you want to
create a JavaScript file, you
can simply create this
file from the Google
Drive Create menu.
And then you can just write
JavaScript code in the same
way that you can work
on Google Documents.
So for example if you rename
the file from here it will
update the file on Google
Drive instantly.
And let me make this program
more sophisticated.
So if you are working on these
files, you will find a lot of
menu items that may look
familiar to you, because we
tried to stay as close to
Google Docs as we could.
So you can, for example, open
the revision history and see
all the changes that
have been saved.
And you can restore the
revisions just in the same way
that you can do it
with Google Docs.
So that was quite easy.
So I thought, if that was easy
then I could also add some
HTML and CSS editors.
And so I came up with--
let me just share this with--
the other editor types, so they
all have their own icon.
So if you open or if you see
these files in a folder you
can just see at first sight if
that's an HTML file, CSS file
or a JavaScript file.
And you can also open multiple
files at once by selecting
both of them and clicking
on Open With Editey.
And this will give you
a simple view of both
files side by side.
So this makes working on
these files quite easy.
And of course all changes will
automatically be saved on
Google Drive.
You can just resize the
different panels and you can
open as many files as you
like in this view.
So if you have multiple files
of the same type they will
just be stacked in
the tap panel.
And the nice thing is that on
Google Drive there's a secret
feature, I would call it, that
allows you to publish files on
the web as a website.
So if you click on the folder
and select share public on the
web, then you can really
launch these files as a
website on the web.
And let me show you
how this works.
So if you--
maybe I was too fast.
If you click on the folder and
say, Open With Editey, then it
will open the website in the
preview mode, I would call it,
or the website mode.
So you have the different
source files on
the left hand side.
And you get a preview
of this website on
the right hand side.
So this is quite nice, to do
some kind of prototyping right
on the web.
Because you now can just launch
this website, post it
on Google Drive on the web.
And if you make any changes
to your source code, it's
instantly visible
on Google Drive.
But if you are working on a
real-world website you don't
want to have this URL
starting with
Google Drive or something.
You just want to have it
on your own domain.
So if you are using Google Apps,
you are able to map end
applications on Google
App Engine to
your Google Apps domain.
And so I just took advantage
of this feature.
And so if you're a Google Apps
customer, and you have a
verified domain, then you can
simply publish this website to
your own domain.
And it's not really doing
any copy stuff.
It will just tell our
application that if someone
goes to this domain, it will put
some proxy stuff to solve
the pages from Google Drive
but it will look as if it
would come from your
own custom domain.
So that's quite nice, because
you can make changes on your
website and they will instantly
be visible right on
your domain.
And so if anybody's interested,
this example--
now it's live.
Everybody can go to this page
and if you click on the sketch
of paper plane, then it
will trigger Ultradox.
So if you go to this website for
the first time you have to
authorize access to your
Google+ profile.
And this will then take some
data from your Google+
profile, send it to our Ultradox
application and
Ultradox will--
should, let's see--
so it will create a mail
and send it to you.
And you will find a paper
plane attached with your
Google+ photo, with a QR
code, and your name.
And you can print it and---
STEVE BAZYL: Make it fun.
Hopefully it flies well.
That's really cool.
And it's nice to see how the two
apps all tie together and
really let people do
some really cool
stuff with Google Drive.
DANIEL FLOREY: And it's really
fun to see that you can really
use and take advantage of all
the Google APIs for just
creating such a simple web site
where you just call a
bunch of APIs and it instantly
works off of Google Drive.
So no magic sort of
stuff included.
AUDIENCE: Was it hard to have
those different icons for the
different content types?
DANIEL FLOREY: That was
something quite tricky,
because basically we just
created a single application.
And so if you are creating an
application for Google Drive
you typically just create
a single icon for this
application.
And I would really recommend
everybody to try to make a
nice icon, because then your
first impression on the Chrome
Web Store will be much better.
So I came up with a solution--
let me try to switch
to another video.
So if you have a look at the
Google API console, we created
a bunch of projects just to be
able to provide the different
file icons and map them to--
so this for example is the
JavaScript editor.
It comes with a set of
JavaScript file icons and is
mapped to the JavaScript
[INAUDIBLE].
And if you are creating a
new document, then this
URL would be called.
And we distinguish the different
file types by their
sub-domain.
And so once our application gets
called the first Create
time with this Create action,
then we can create the proper
file type and redirect the user
more or less to our main
Editey application.
So they are all working
on the same
application, on App Engine.
So that's important to allow
people to share files and
stuff like that.
But to get a different file
icons, we had to create this
application and the Google API
console for each file type.
STEVE BAZYL: This is something
that we could probably
certainly make easier for
applications like yourself,
like yours, where you create
different types of content
with the same application and
wanting to have those
represented as distinct
actions.
So definitely something that
we'll add to that to the list
of feature requests.
DANIEL FLOREY: It really depends
where you want to have
the complexity.
Because if you allow multiple
file items and icons in the
API console, then the console
itself may get quite
complicated.
But really, from a user
perspective it would be really
nice if you were to have a
Create menu on Google Drive.
Maybe with a sub menu for the
different file types that an
application can handle
and create.
But maybe it's just a very
special case, I don't know.
But probably other users
may come up with the
same request as well.
STEVE BAZYL: The downside to
having multiple applications
is you end up having to
authorize multiple application
to read the content.
So if you're constantly
switching between content, or
at least that first couple times
of loading all those
apps and authorizing could
be a little bit onerous.
But they're really cool apps.
And I've actually installed
these on my own account and
have started using them.
They're really nicely done, and
I love that they're very
familiar to myself, certainly,
as somebody who uses Docs on a
daily basis.
It feels like it's just another
version of Google Docs
that handles all the--
DANIEL FLOREY: I think if you're
a small company, I
think it's really my
recommendation to stay with
something that a bigger
company has developed.
So for example, Twitter
Bootstrap, I think that's
quite great instead of starting
to create your own
style sheets and stuff
like that.
If you're a small company,
why try to
reinvent everything yourself?
So I think it's just fair
to just more or
less copy their layout.
Especially if you're focusing
on the same user base.
And I think it's also good
for the Google Drive--
be consistent with all
the applications.
Look at least a little
bit familiar.
STEVE BAZYL: Certainly we
encourage people to have their
own brand, but having certain
conventions, and usability
standards, and everything really
helps in making users
feel comfortable with those
applications and reduce that
learning curve.
So great job on those
applications.
Do you have-- other than, it was
a great trick with showing
the multiple applications.
Is there anything else that
comes to mind that developers
who might be thinking about
building apps for Drive--
tips that you might share, or
any advice for how to be
successful?
DANIEL FLOREY: I think maybe
when starting a new
application I think it's really
a good idea to find out
what is the right granularity
if you want to share stuff.
Because it makes sense to take
most of functionality that is
available, like sharing and
revision history and maybe
real time API and all the stuff
that you get more or
less for free.
You just have to provide
a nice user interface.
But the product part is
already done for you.
And so I think you have to make
sure that you find the
right size of pieces
that you want to
share with other users.
For example, if it comes to
contact sharing I think it
would not make much sense to
have this file item on Google
Drive for each contact.
Maybe it would make sense to
have one icon or one item for
a contact group, or whatever.
So I think if you find the
proper size of items that you
want to share and you want to
work on, then you can really
take a lot of advantage
from the
features that are available.
OLIVER ZEIGERMANN: Talking
about real time API?
There's stuff in the pipeline
for real time API.
DANIEL FLOREY: Yes.
So, definitely.
So we are planning right now.
Editey, we started with the
very simple, basic stuff.
And there's--
at least in the midterm we are
planning to fill the missing
features that you would find
on Google Docs, like
commenting and [INAUDIBLE] and
real time collaboration.
And so we are looking to
integrate that into Editey
over the next weeks.
So that's something that is a
little bit difficult for us
because we still are using
the Web Toolkit for our
applications.
And we have a bunch of
components that we can reuse
in every application.
So we may stick with it for a
while even though it's not the
hottest stuff.
As we are using Google Web
Toolkit, of course, we have to
write a Google Web Toolkit
wrapper for the real time API.
So that takes some time.
But once that is done, it's
quite easy to add features.
STEVE BAZYL: I'd be curious to,
as you make more progress
on that, to learn a little bit
more about your experience and
how that goes, and some
of the challenges.
Maybe it may turn out
to be really easy.
Personally, I love the
real time API.
It's really fun to play with--
DANIEL FLOREY: So if anyone
interested, we've also open
sourced our Google Web Toolkit
wrapper for the picker.
So you will find that
on Google Code.
So I think that if you are using
Google Web Toolkit and
want to leverage some features
from the Google Drive API you
can just check out the code
from Google Code.
And this will give you
a nice good wrapper
for the picker API.
STEVE BAZYL: That's great
and good to know.
Do you know what the URL
is for that offhand?
Or a project name that people
can search for?
DANIEL FLOREY: I think it's
Good Google Picker,
something like that?
I can share it with you later.
STEVE BAZYL: Or post to the
Google+ community, I know
you've been active
there as well.
It'd be great if you just
share a link to that for
people who are interested in
using GWT and Drive together,
that's a nice bit of reasonable
functionality that
they can just pick
up very quickly.
So I really look forward to
seeing what happens with the
real time API and Editey,
as well as
new features in Ultradox.
Again, it's a really
cool application.
And thanks to both of you
for being here today.
I know it's late on your end,
and you've probably had a long
day already.
But I really appreciate you
taking the time to join us and
tell us about what you've
been doing.
And we'll certainly touch base
again after you've played
around with things in the
real time API and
see how things go.
That's all for today.
For next week, we'll be here
talking about tips and tricks
and some best practices for
Google Drive, and how to do
certain optimizations and make
your apps perform better.
So we'll nail down that details,
and share it on the
Google+ community.
Until then, we'll see
you guys next week.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]